arizona cardinals and new england
patriots two star quarterbacks not star
performances from either one it was ugly
it was back and forth cardinals had a
double-digit lead and they blew it there
have been 35 games so far this season
the most through 12 weeks in any season
of the national football league where
teams have erased double-digit deficits
and come back to win the game no
it's one of two yesterday that has
something that's well that's right now
the patriots were at home
but uh you know on the road it makes it
easier to come from behind when you
don't have the crowd noise to put the
hammer down and pin the ears back for
defensive linemen and get after
quarterbacks yeah even though
you know you feel the pressure and
tension in the building even if you do
you don't get booed right you don't get
booed right or you know oh it's you know
the second and third down on a must-have
drive and you hear the blues and the
murmurs already and now it's third and
fourth down and the whole team feels you
know that pressure that's a real thing
too so i i think that is part of of why
we're seeing so many of these come back
sorry to interrupt you no that's a good
point i mean it's once every few weeks
there's one of those awkward moments
where a supposedly good team
has to go to the locker room and you
hear that that
is that the noise is kind of like that's
kind of like a dying walrus
i have a feeling we're gonna hear that
one again at some point uh anyway um
kyler murray after after getting himself
onto the short list of mvp candidates
following the hail mary two rough games
since then the seahawks bottled them up
from a running standpoint last thursday
night the cardinals were bottled up
again
by the patriots on sunday now murray's
got that shoulder injury they tried to
be very coy about he was limited in
practice much of the week i don't know
how much that affected him you know it's
the patriots right and the patriots will
uh come up with ways from time to time
to shut you down they will take away
what you do best they tried to do it
last week with
with shaw watson and the texans and they
couldn't this week with kyler murray
they could they took away what the
cardinals do best which is get the ball
to the andre hopkins and let kyle murray
wreak havoc with his legs yeah well you
know as we always talk about it's a
match-up game the arizona offense i
think matched up a little bit better
with new england as far as as far as on
new england side of it being able to
cover and do certain things to stop some
of their schemes down the field and all
that but hey this is the third game in a
row we've seen
not necessarily
a great offensive passing attack from
the cardinals yeah i know the hail
murray play right you know the hail
murray play we got to remember if he
doesn't complete the hail murray he's
throwing for 198 201 yards in that game
of course the seattle game the next week
solid but not great not what we've come
to expect out of kyla murray in the
cardinals offense and then yesterday so
you know it's something that i know i
brought up to you i do feel like
defensive coordinators have caught on to
have some of their schemes and past
patterns down the field and then the
next thing is okay can we figure out a
plan to stop kyla murray from running
around and making us look silly and new
england had that and then i mean it just
seemed like every big moment right mike
new england made the play and the
cardinals didn't i mean specifically
that little stretch we saw at the end of
the first half where the cardinals have
a chance to go up 17-7 and you're going
man the way the patriots offense looks
today they go down by 10 points this
could be over and they make the goal
line stand there like you said new
england's unbelievable they play
complimentary football
and all three phases every week show up
and like yesterday you look at special
teams they had a huge kick return and a
huge punt return that helped them score
and that was a big part of the football
game and that's where bill belichick is
just amazing to me
and that's why the terminator is not
dead never dead so the terminator is
dead this dynamic with the cardinals
that has unfolded since the
murray you know there other teams
struggle with this and i think the
vikings in particular kyle rudolph
explained this to me a few weeks ago
when you have a big
loss or a big win that happens at the
very end that's either a punch in the
gut or an unexpected exaltation you
still have to
keep playing games right and sometimes
you get so caught up in that moment that
it throws you off especially you know
either when it's bad and one loss
becomes two as you like to say or when
it's really good
and and you you you can't get back into
your grind you feel like hey you know
we're pretty good it's like yeah you
still got games to play guys and now
you've lost two in a row since then so i
know there's other factors that go into
it but i can't help but wonder
whether that was you know like this
postseason excitement moment for the
cardinals while they still had a lot of
games to play and they've they really
have lost their way since then they
definitely have i mean it is not it
wasn't good football against the seattle
seahawks on thursday night
and you know had a week off you know a
long week to prepare for the patriots
and didn't look special yesterday
certainly i mean had chances to win the
football game i mean we know that missed
a field goal at the end that could have
put them up 20 to 17 made things
different but we haven't seen that magic
to what you're talking about we don't
see the magical connection that we saw
hopkins and kyla murray early in the
year that kind of seems to be few and
far between at certain parts of the
football game and then what i really
think is just
teams have figured out like i've said
the cliff kingsbury plain of attack a
little bit with the passing game
and
how they want to attack kyler murray too
and we saw that i know we broke it down
last night but with kyla murray hey the
patriots so many times you know looked
like they show blitz they got two spies
you know in the middle of the field for
kylo murray if they want to throw the
ball short and over the middle which
they might do a lot or just get the
hands out quick with the quick passing
game they had people all over the
passing lanes i mean we showed chase
vinovich the whole defense is jumping up
they were their whole job was wait this
guy's small and fast let's not over
pursue we'll kind of just mush rush and
keep him in front of us
get our hands up that takes away his
ability to throw a lot of footballs
because again he is small and he's not
perfect that hurts his game and then
within that because they're just looking
to time the jump they're in a position
to oh wait he's scrambling all right i'm
in a good spot to go out and contain
them there or go there and that was
where it was really brilliant by by bill
belichick and stephen belichick and what
the patriots did
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports